hello I'm gab I'm done we're the slow mo
guys Dan you know what else is a bloody
good channel to the hydraulic press
channel yes pretty sweet we've got one
here it's massive yeah sighs the thing
actually goes about probably 12 15 feet
up in the air
it's huge and I've learnt from that
channel that pretty much anything
explodes if you press on it hard enough
including debit cards which are just so
happen to have in my car and we've never
seen I've never seen the hydraulic press
blow something up in slow motion no so
we're going to film this at 28,000 500
frames a second which is over a thousand
times slower than you can see with your
own face so I'm a hydraulic press
channel the cards explode basically so
to protect us and the camera we've had
to put this big screen in front of us
because I don't really particularly want
a piece of card going through my jugular
as we're filming kill bodies to space
yeah so if it does explode I want to be
protected instead of thankfully this
hydraulic press you can see all the way
through to the other side but typically
it's quite hard to light inside
machinery like that and we've also got
ourselves a lovely bright light here
that I'm blasting down in the faces
right now so we should get some nice
exposure on this
oh my
what do we got left it's this than this
so this is actually all 52 cards
compressed as much as possible hook so
technically this is a full deck of cards
right here every single card in the deck
the world thinnest sort of like crushes
it back to two wood it does it's pretty
solid I want to kind of snap I thought
we were gonna die yeah look glad we had
the cover because all the cards flung
out everywhere all over the floor well I
thought that was a lovely little tribute
video there nice quick easy one pick a
card any card okay well you got the Jack
Jack of Diamonds there yeah yeah you
weren't supposed to show me but oh sorry
yep well all you have to do is say is
this job yah yah yah yah because it's
definitely every card yeah all right
well feel free to follow us on Twitter
we've got some merch we've got a lovely
second channel and do let us know in the
comments if you'd like to see any more
slo-mo hydraulic press I'm sure we can
make that one happen this is the only
one that's intact
alright we'll see you in the next one